hi everyone Sal Khan here and welcome to
middle school biology I have Iman Howard
here who manages our stem content
welcome Iman and why should folks care
about middle school biology
biology is the study of life and so in
this course it really answers why are
things the way they are why do you look
the way they do why do I look the way I
do and how every organism on Earth has a
really special purpose and a special
treat and based on these traits it helps
them interact with their environment we
even talk about energy and energy can't
be created and it can't be destroyed it
actually Cycles as matter through an
ecosystem and it even has this really
cool chemical reactions called
photosynthesis where plants use light
energy from the Sun and they make their
own food which is insane I think about
organisms like the gorilla that are
super big and strong and they don't go
and eat a cow they go and eat plants
because that's like getting energy right
from the source and then finally we talk
about Evolution based on our traits how
have we changed over time and how some
of our natural traits were selected by
the environment that create the those
changes or even how humans we have
something called artificial selection
which explains why your dog's so cute
whether it's a hundred pounds or five
pounds we did that what do you think is
cool about itself
oh well biology is trying to enter I
mean to your point the questions of Life
which we still don't understand a lot
about but like what makes us us and to
realize that we aren't we don't exist as
human beings in isolation we're part of
an ecosystem we're part of a story a
narrative that's been going on for
millions and billions of years the fact
that we're made up of trillions of cells
each of them with DNA that can describe
who we are how did all of this
complexity come about this is maybe the
most mind-blowing topic that we're
really at just the beginning of this
journey so I think folks are going to be
really really excited to or it's going
to be really interesting to see see all
the things that they get to learn
well let's dig in